salud en directo américa más romero sala
con nosotros en el estudio esta mañana
de jueves mark vamos a ver cuánto tiempo
vamos a tener nosotros para saber el
origen del cómic 19 porque eso lo digo
porque vamos a el siglo 14 han
descubierto el origen de la peste negra
que sabe más hasta el momento si
efectivamente raúl muy buenos días 700
años para descubrir este origen vamos a
ver cuántos pasan para el hobbit
recordemos antes de nada va a explicar
que la peste negra fue la mayor epidemia
de la historia la mayor pandemia perdón
que se ha conocido que ccoo matar entre
un tercio y la mitad de la población de
todo el continente europeo y su origen
había sido un misterio hasta ahora que
un equipo de genetistas y también de
arqueólogos tanto de alemania como de
reino unido hallaron la primera bacteria
y los resultados se publicaron en la
revista en hecha aquí vemos el árbol de
las distintas variantes y la que aparece
en morado es esta que se ha encontrado y
que se considera que es la original en
contra la encontraron en tumbas de una
pequeña población de kirguistán que
están asia central y había llamado la
atención porque había muchas más tumbas
de los que debería ser habitual para la
época y para el tamaño de la ciudad no
los dientes de algunos de estos
esqueletos encontraron la bacteria y de
nuevo no fue cualquiera sino la que se
considera la original como lo supieron
pues porque se considera que a finales
del siglo 14 hubo una especie de big
band' de variantes y esta pues después
de estudios genómicos se encontró que
era previa a este big bang' de variantes
entonces por eso se ha considerado que
al menos es la que más vieja se ha
encontrado y que estaría relacionada con
ese origen de la peste negra además de
esta población pues estaba en la ruta
del paso de la ruta de la seda que iba
hacia europa desde asia europa y pues a
partir de ahí fue que se empezó a
diseminar esta enfermedad además también
vemos en los colores de más amarillentos
y verdes cómo fue cambiando y cómo fue
provocando nuevas oleadas de enfermedad
algo que nos recuerda al cob inyección a
beta así es y hablando de estas dos
pandemias le pregunto de si hay
similitudes pues por supuesto hay varias
hay muchas lecciones también que extraer
el raúl la primera es fuera al final la
peste negra fue la primera gran crisis
de salud que existió y que afectó al
mundo de manera global pero centrándonos
al menos en el tema del origen como bien
al inicio no 700 años para encontrarlo
quizás nos deberían enseñar que tenemos
que tener algo de paciencia para
encontrar el origen también del comité
su nave quizás no va a ir tan rápido
salvando las distancias del conocimiento
y la tecnología que se tienen hoy en día
pero es que luego también queríamos
poner un momento la atención sobre esta
teoría que hubo al inicio también de que
el origen del cómic fue creado por un
laboratorio chino algo parecido pasó con
la peste negra pero en ese momento el
chivo expiatorio fueron las comunidades
judías a las que se culpaba de que pues
diseminaban deliberadamente esta
bacteria en ese momento de hecho no se
sabía que era una bacteria y eso llevó a
persecución desplazamiento de
comunidades judías enteras y desarrolló
políticas xenófobas hacia quien podía
entrar a las ciudades oa los países
siete siglos después hemos visto pasar
cosas parecidas lo mismo que sucedió con
la discriminación hacia la población
hacia hasta la población asiática perdón
al inicio de la pandemia o cierres de
fronteras que luego vimos que eran más
arbitrarios que reales por motivos
sanitarios claro más más políticos que
otra cosa seguimos hablando de nuestro
momento en nuestra pandemia que todavía
la tenemos 19 estaba dejamos hablar de
las vacunas para la población infantil
si avancemos en el índico volvemos a hoy
en día la sda que recordemos que es del
ente regulador tanto de medicamentos
como de alimentos en eeuu dio finalmente
luz verde a la vacuna fighter entre los
6 y los 4 años de edad ya la vacuna de
moderna entre los 6 meses y los 5 años
de edad escuchemos uno de los
comentarios durante el debate
creo que los beneficios superan con
creces los riesgos
[Música]
personalmente realmente creo que esta
recomendación cubre una necesidad para
una población joven ignorada que
necesita opciones las familias ahora
tendrán una opción que no tenían antes
por ejemplo estamos hablando de niños
con una condiciones de salud previa que
pues quieren protegerse de una manera
especial contra el commit 19 según la
sda por ejemplo hasta la fecha 442 son
los menores de 5 años que han muerto por
esta enfermedad una cifra que es muy
significativa pero que no deja de ser
proporcionalmente menor a lo que sucede
en otros grupos de edad de hecho se cree
que por eso podrían haber pocas familias
que en realidad eligiera de esa opción
de proteger a sus menores de edad
menores de 5 años contra el cob y por
ejemplo la vacuna a facer que ya está
aprobada para los niños entre 5 y 11
años de edad en ese rango sólo un 29 por
ciento de los niños están completamente
vacunados marc le pregunto si tenemos
datos de esta eficacia las vacunas
contra la población infantil así pues en
este mismo debate y conferencia de la
edad muestra los datos de moderna los de
facer no porque en su estudio no hubo
suficientes de niños que se contagiaron
de kobe como para tener datos
significativos pero en lo que respecta a
moderna vamos a repasar esas cifras que
dijo la sda el organismo estadounidense
vemos que entre los 6 y los 2 años de
edad un 50 por ciento más o menos de los
casos de niños vacunados fueron
protegidos contra la enfermedad
sintomática esa eficacia baja cuando
vamos a entre los 2 y los 6 años de edad
el 36 por ciento vemos que es una cifra
realmente diferente a las cifras de
protección que tenemos por ejemplo pues
con la población adulta pero recordemos
que al final la pregunta que responde la
sda no es qué tan eficaces sino si los
riesgos superan los beneficios y en este
caso la conclusión fue que si bueno marc
muchísimas gracias como siempre por toda
la información de saludos mañana con más
pasamos a saludar a nuestra